american military news comes out
yesterday two days ago russia warns
world war iii very risk is very
significant so russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov warned on monday that the
risk of a third world war cannot be
underestimated and said the u.s and nato
are adding to the risk by supplying
weapons to ukraine lavrov said
russia agreed on the in the
admissibility of nuclear war and said
avoiding such conflict as our principal
position however
he warned that now the risks are very
significant he particularly criticized
the us for supplying man portable
anti-aircraft missile launchers and
anti-tank javelin missiles which he said
could be used for terrorist attacks so
is this just a threat or is this a bluff
or do you think things can get pretty
ugly
there you know what happens when you
compute capitulate to a bully
they keep moving
you know this is it a threat yeah is
that threat is it a serious threat
i don't know um i know that they're
they're losing and they know that and so
they're getting desperate and so they're
making these crazy uh
accus
or threats uh but
frankly
you know the moment we capitulate is the
moment the world becomes
more dangerous not less dangerous
because the bully understands where the
red line doesn't mean a red line anymore
and when they start getting away with
a nuclear threat then what happens in in
estonia
when they when the russian ethnic
population in estonia that putin is
stirring up right now
you know he what happens when he gets
them to do like what he did in eastern
ukraine and say they they're not having
their interest protected and russia's
got to go in there now and protect them
well no their nato country
you know so if if if moscow goes in into
estonia i i you know are we going to
give in
and if we've given in on the nuclear
threat on ukraine
we'll give in on the nuclear threat in
estonia and all of a sudden the balkans
go back all of a sudden sweden and
finland are talking about maybe becoming
a part of nato why
because they feel threatened now they've
been for years they've always said
neutrality we don't need to be a part of
nato all of a sudden they're changing
germany i mean like i mean this is one
of those big surprises to me
yeah the chancellor of germany is a
social democrat which is the party
that's affiliated with putin's party you
know where you have these affiliations
internationally
uh and he's rearing germany
amazing i mean it's just historic why
because now germany started this guy
recognizes his country is worried i mean
he's got his relationships with putin
but the country is worried that
germany's borders now are good good
potential we have to be worried that
should the world be worried if germany
starts arming itself i mean they don't
exactly have the best reputation oh they
got arms right but the point of getting
that is you've got all these things
things swirling around nothing is black
and white putin is causing all of the
swirling around
and so when he starts threatening us
with doomsday
and we give in
it's not going to get better it's going
to get worse so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]